>> I'M SO SCARED.
>> SHH.
DON'T LET THE MONSTERS HEAR US!
WE HAVE TO BE QUIET.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> YOU GUYS --
>> SHH.
SHH.
>> KANYE JUST TWEETED.
>>ED DAVID, SHH!
>> HE SAID HE WOULD HAVE VOTED
FOR TRUMP!
>> WAIT, SERIOUSLY, WHEN?
>> GUYS!
DON'T TALK UNLESS IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
THE MONSTERS CAN'T SEE US, BUT
THEY CAN HEAR US.
AND IF WE'RE TOO LOUD, WE'LL ALL
BE KILLED!
>> BUT KANYE HAS THE HAT AND
EVERYTHING.
AND TRUMP SIGNED IT.
HE SIGNED THE HAT, Y'ALL.
>> LET ME SEE THIS.
>> OH, COME ON, KANYE!
♪♪♪
>> TRUMP TWEETED KANYE.
>> KANYE IS A DISTRACTION.
WE SHOULD ONLY TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT.
>> LIKE HOW TO SURVIVE THE
MONSTERS?
>> AND THEN I GUESS ALSO LIKE
THE MIDTERMS.
'CAUSE LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I CAN'T KEEP UP.
>> GUYS, THEY'RE AT
CHRISSY TEIGAN'S HOUSE.
>> NO, KANYE!
LEAVE CHRISSY TEIGAN OUT OF
THIS.
>> IT REALLY FEELS LIKE DAMAGE
CONTROL.
DID CHRISSY TEIGAN COOK
ANYTHING?
>> GUMBO.
>> SHH, THE MONSTERS WILL HEAR
US.
>> YEAH, WHY ARE WE EVEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS?
>> BECAUSE IT'S OUT THERE.
IT'S ALL OUT THERE.
AND GUESS WHO WAS AT THE BABY
SHOWER?
JESSE TYLER FERGUSON.
>> FROM "MODERN" FREAKING
"FAMILY?"
♪♪♪
>> OH, MY GOD, SHE'S GONE.
>> IF WE DIE HERE, WHAT IF KANYE
IS JUST PLAYING US.
>> YOU THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING?
THAT IS SO SCARY.
>> AND KANYE JUST RELEASED A NEW
TRACK.
>> WHAT?
BUT WE CAN'T TAKE THE RISK OF
LISTENING TO IT.
TWO PEOPLE JUST GOT TAKEN BY
MONSTERS.
>> I'VE GOT EAR BUDS.
>> THEN QUEUE IT UP, BITCH.
♪♪♪
>> YOU IDIOTS.
>> DID HE JUST SAY, "POOPITY
SCOOP?"
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
NONE OF THIS MATTERS.
>> I NEED TO KNOW IF HE SAID,
"POOPITY-SCOOP."
HE SAID, "POOPITY --"
♪♪♪
>> OH, NO, THE RED LIGHTS.
IT'S AN EMERGENCY.
>> I KNOW, KANYE WAS JUST ON TMZ
AND HE SAID, "SLAVERY WAS A
CHOICE."
>> NO!
♪♪♪
>> I DON'T WANT YA'LL TO CALL ME
FAT, SO I GO LIPOSUCTION.
RIGHT?
AND THEY GAVE ME OPIOIDS.
♪ POOPITY SCOOP ♪
>> HMM, KINDA GROWS ON YOU.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]